la veille de l'ouverture du du palace il
y a une grande fête et vous êtes monté
au premier balcon tout nu sur une
échelle et et évidemment quand vous
étiez en haut le type A Tirer l'échelle
et vous avez été obligé de sauter tout
nu au milieu des danseurs
ça va très bien alors Kenzo après 3 ans
de retraite vous qu'on a toujours
surnommé le plus parisien des Japonais
faites votre come-back d'abord avec de
la musique vous avez créé un label chez
Sony musique qui s'appelle KT comme
Kenzo Takada puisque c'est votre nom et
vous ne pouvez plus utiliser votre seul
prénom depuis la vente de la société
Kenzo à LVMH la société de Bernard
Arnault en 1993 alors on dit que vous
avez vendu votre société 100 millions
d'euros qui ne veut pas dire vous pouvez
pas le dire
alors sur le label KT vous sortez un
disque premier disque donc ils sont vos
musiques préférées le disque s'appelle
sensation pourpre et c'est bien celui-là
qu'il faut demander dans les magasins
enfin c'est toutes les musiques qui vous
plaisent quoi il y a pas un lien
particulier comme beaucoup les voyages
qui fassent voyager la vie en rose Kenzo
évidemment ça rappelle des des souvenirs
Grace Jones les années palaces et pour
moi beaucoup beaucoup de souvenirs avec
Grèce surtout l'année 70
elle a commencé aussi comme mannequin et
bon on a on se voyait beaucoup on
sortait beaucoup et puis quand elle a
commencé chanter
même à New York on a j'ai fait défilé et
les bougnou chanter pour défiler et
vraiment on est très copain
alors moi je me souviens de vous au
Palace il y a eu quand même des
histoires extraordinaires avec Enzo je
me souviens un jour vous étiez habillé
en minima ou quand même en souvenez on
dirait pas quand on vous voit comme ça
mais oui
on en reparlera tout à l'heure avec
Guillaume Canet et François Berléand
parce que dans le film de Guillaume
Canet mon idole il s'habille en
kangourou et un lapin donc on pense à
vous habiller en souri et puis alors il
y a une histoire encore pire c'est la
veille de l'ouverture du palace il y a
une grande fête et vous êtes monté au
premier balcon tout nu sur une échelle
et évidemment quand vous étiez en haut
le type à tirer l'échelle et vous avez
été obligé de sauter tout nu au milieu
des danseurs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors on va voir maintenant comment le
petit Kenzo au tacada est devenu une
star mondiale de la mode c'est toute une
histoire vous êtes né à imager au Japon
en 1939 ce qui fait que vous avez 63 ans
et je dois dire c'est incroyable
vraiment
alors vous êtes Kenzo le cinquième d'une
famille de 7 enfants vos parents
tenaient une maison de thé et très jeune
en fait vous dévorez les magazines de
mode de vos soeurs aînées
j'ai tout petit déjà ça vous fascinait
oui
c'est jeune quand même et le premier
grand choc de votre vie c'est quand vous
voyez au cinéma les quatre filles du
docteur March et vous voyez un lit et à
ce moment-là vous êtes tellement à vide
de connaître l'Occident que vous
demandez à votre mère dans fabriquer un
lit
occidental dans l'endroit où elle
rangeait les futons
d'ailleurs
j'ai fait comme comme dit voilà comme un
lit et alors quelques années plus tard
vous vous ennuyez à mourir à
l'université de Kobe
quand l'école de mode japonaise bonca
décide d'accueillir des garçons et même
Dieu demandé mon père ma mère
il voulait pas du tout que je fasse ça
mais
quand je suis entre université du monde
et je suis parti j'ai gagné l'argent
pendant les vacances et je suis parti à
Tokyo et puis je suis entré l'école de
monde voilà et là vous avez travaillé
très dur vous étiez apprendre-t-il
sous-payés chez un peintre d'enseigne
pendant le jour la nuit vous prépariez
vos examens avec des cours du soir des
leçons par correspondance vous aviez
vraiment ça chevillé au corps pendant 6
mois pendant 6 mois j'ai promis de
travailler et finalement
ma mère et la tombée
de entre corps du monde
et là au bout de quelques temps vous
décidez de vous rendre en France pays de
la mode s'il en est un et vous partez à
bord d'un bateau qui s'appelle le
Cambodge
c'était le 30 novembre 64 et pour moi
pour moi c'était première fois j'ai
sorti du Japon et un mois dans un bateau
quand même c'était le premier vacances
64 à la fin de 64 et on a passé par
rencontre Saigon
Singapour
Alexandrie et Marseille c'est un sacré
c'était un sacré voyage donc un mois et
vous avez 24 ans lorsque vous débarquez
à Marseille et ce voyage vous a
influencé finalement on peut dire que
votre mode World un peu fusion de toutes
les cultures a été inspiré par ça et
époque quand j'ai voyagé dans le bateau
je pensais pas pour mon travail et tout
mais après quand j'ai commencé 70
mon identité tous les souvenirs dans
cette voyage exotisme et comme ça qui
m'a beaucoup inspiré alors après
Marseille évidemment vous montez à Paris
première réaction il fait pas très beau
le ciel est gris et les femmes sont
habillées comme dans les magazines de
mode que vous lisiez au Japon vous étiez
arrivés à l'endroit où vous allez
c'était oui époque c'était
tous les dieux tous les jours je suis
alléchanger il y avait
le store qui était là il y a yeah
et puis dans la Champs-Élysées il y a
beaucoup presque tous les femmes qui qui
sont habillés à Chanel
et c'était vraiment très très jolie très
dur pour vous parce que vous habitez
dans une chambre de bonne à Clichy j'ai
commencé
alors ce qui est extraordinaire chez
Kenzo donc il est arrivé ici il y a
presque 40 ans et
vous parliez déjà aussi mal le français
que maintenant c'est à dire incroyable
c'est extraordinaire avec Kenzo c'est
quand une quarantaine d'années ça
faisait aucun problème
j'ai fait beaucoup d'efforts quand même
oui je sais que vous faites des efforts
de français non on m'a dit que vous
parliez aussi mal en japonais c'est vrai
oui des problèmes de par les ni japonais
ni français et quand
mes amis japonais pourquoi tu pars pas
bien en France japonais il pense
beaucoup comme j'habite à Paris Djibril
japonais n'a pas de tout ça mais Kenzo
quel est votre langue d'expression
l'anglais vous parlez bien anglais
non non
c'est facile
donc à Paris au début vous faites des
petits boulots pour survivre alors
est-ce que vous avez été tendeur pour
chien
non ça c'était quand j'étais
Alliance française j'ai cherché travail
et pour des
ce travail finalement
j'étais pas habitué avec ça ça marchait
pas finalement non
mais en fait c'est très difficile pour
vous à cette époque-là vous vous
apprêtez d'ailleurs à repartir au Japon
parce que vous êtes très très déçu de ce
qui se passe et à ce moment-là vous
vendez 5 croquis à Louis Féro et ça y
est bon ça a été le début d'une énorme
carrière ensuite avec katsuko Kondo que
vous aviez connu à l'école boulka oui
vous ouvrez une petite boutique galerie
Vivienne qui s'appelle jungle [ __ ] et
puis Kenzo est né la presse suit enfin
on connaît la suite mais je voulais
raconter les difficultés du départ et
l'énergie qui vous a fallu pour vous
sortir du petit village d'immeji pour
arriver jusqu'à la Place des Victoires
quand même eu pas mal d'aventures
beaucoup d'aventures vous êtes
intéressés par le Japon vous Olivier les
geisha tout ça c'est quelque chose qui
vous tente non pas du tout
non moi je suis intéressé par l'histoire
militaire japonaise du 14e 15e 16e
siècle je vous intéresse
voilà vous m'avez posé une question vous
avez une réponse maintenant
voilà et puis après bon la mode se met
au noir se met au sexy vous dites je
n'ai jamais su sculpter une robe donc
c'est vrai que la mode change un peu
puis après ça devient la mode des années
70 c'est comme vous l'aviez déjà fait
une fois celle-là vous avez pas envie de
la recommencer c'est vous qui l'aviez
inventé et puis vous avez 60 ans quoi si
vous voulez un petit peu profiter de la
vie et vous avez vous avez raison vous
les voyagez bref comme on dit prendre
votre retraite un peu lassé aussi par le
fait que le marketing est aux commandes
dans la mode c'est Dieu travaille
pendant 30 ans très fort
et très dur c'était bien aussi mais un
moment j'étais perdu
et l'apothéose donc de votre carrière de
couturier ça a été le Zénith vous avez
fait votre défilé d'adieu et puis un
jour en décembre 99 vous organisez un
superbe réveillon dans votre maison de
Phuket en Thaïlande et quand vos amis
rentrent à Paris vous vous retrouvez
tout seul et vous vous demandez c'est
terrible vous vous demandez ce que vous
allez faire alors évidemment vous faites
de la gymnastique vous prenez des cours
de français fait de la peinture faites
beaucoup de peinture vous étudiez un
petit peu internet enfin bon ça c'est
des trucs de retraité quoi au bout d'un
moment ça fatigue et il faut vous rendre
à l'évidence le travail vous manque et
vous recommencez à faire des vêtements
finalement oui finalement
j'aime bien mon métier
donc
vous créez une ligne qui s'appelle Yuma
ce qui veut dire rêve en japonais et
bientôt il y aura alors
n'arrivez pas à faire autrement parce
que bientôt il y aura une boutique dans
un palace thaï à Phuket donc vous
recommencez tous les boutiques vous
allez recréer un deuxième empire quoi
uniquement ce que j'aime
trop trop poussées
voilà et vous sortez ce disque donc il
s'appelle sensation pourpre
[Musique]
voilà alors Kenzo comme on l'a vu vous
avez pas eu besoin de d'interprètes pas
besoin de traduction d'oreillettes vous
êtes très très bien débrouillé je vous
félicite mais bon pour arrêter de vous
fatiguer on va vous faire une interview
sans la bouche
[Musique]
voilà donc
est-ce que Kenza du loft est votre sœur
croyez-vous que les Américains vont
faire un Hiroshima en Irak
espèce non
que pensez-vous des hommes qui portent
des costumes noirs
que pensez-vous de moi
[Rires]
jamais été jusqu'à égaré des pensées sur
toi je
non je trouve sympathique puis j'aime
beaucoup de maintenant que tu as pu
t'arrêt sur le côté c'est mieux non je
préfère avant
avant tu faisais preuve des cols libres
maintenant tu fais
à moitié voyou
tracé Kenzo il a touché à la mode il
touche à la musique il va bien de
barbouiller un truc à la coiffure
[Applaudissements]
Kenzo que pensez-vous de vous
que pensez-vous du PSG
ouais
il s'est rattrapé que pensez-vous de la
drogue
ah ouais c'était avant à l'époque où
vous étiez tout nu du premier balcon du
palais c'était une autre époque oui
d'accord que pensez-vous de la religion
ah oui vous êtes bouddhiste oui quand
vous êtes au Japon par exemple vous
allez faire des offrandes au temple
un petit peu
que pensez-vous des gens qui ont tout
pour être heureux
et des gens qui ont rien pour être
heureux
que pensez-vous de cette interview Kenzo
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu